ooh red velvet it doesn't taste like red
velvet at all I like me an initial taste
like I'm like yeah it looked like a cold
cookie and then it just kind of takes me
like maybe the super young generation
maybe your teen could deal with that
kind of sugar but you know I'm an old
guy a chocolate covered raisin or some
of the cover berry I don't want to know
how many calories are in here but I like
it otherwise cotton candy oh my god
that's delicious
it tastes it tastes more like raspberry
I would say than cotton candy but I'm a
big fan of that that double bubble
bubble gum
what is cotton candy it's just sugar
pink milk that all the kids drink and
the xix coffee is very adult II and
cotton candy is very kid-like and it
tastes like something inappropriate an
empty clown's smile
unfortunately so big negative on the
cotton candy we're still at the State
Fair we had cotton candy and now we're
having caramel at least we're getting
into the coffee universe I'm kind of mad
at this one really insane milkshake see
that to me is pretty delicious it is
really sweet but it's dark it's
chocolatey this is the first one that I
really like cinnamon roll this tastes
like the mall okay no oh my god no this
is like um I was gonna actually I'd say
oh well Pillsbury on crack right here I
love lemon bars lemon bars in liquid
form I'm very skeptical of I liked its
summary it's fun and flirty for summer
no I almost feel like this is something
that would make me think not good
there's no tartness to it like I've
never tasted something like this before
it's not even that it's just like whoa
sweet it's like how interesting if you
had cupcake flavor sriracha I'd give it
a shot all right this is this is like a
mutant vanilla bean milkshake it tastes
like a cupcake flavored candle smells
also you can't name a flavor after
something that has multiple flavors what
is this what what cupcake have they
decided is worthy of getting the cupcake
flavor yeah so cupcakes so far my
favorite one because it's the most
subtle please taste like melted frozen
yogurt to shoot
the world's falling apart better to just
go get one of these things and enjoy it
because we're either gonna run out of
water or tornados coming or something so
just get a tree put it in your face
luckily they won't be around for long
I'm excited about the future of
frappuccinos I vote for caramel cocoa
cluster
I vote for Lemon bar finiman role bad
velvet for cupcake I think I vote for
cotton candy this is fantastic
frozen coffee it's a treat to dessert so
you know it has its own place in the
desert world as to where you have a nice
cup of black coffee